[Música]
la llegada al puerto de tánger que de
lyon se dice pasada a las 12 de la noche
de este viernes 4 de diciembre no pasó
desapercibida
por primera vez este edificio flotante
de 400 metros de largo y 70 de alto
recién construido por la naviera
francesa ceemea cgm recaló en un puerto
europeo durante todo el fin de semana
una verdadera coreografía de
contenedores y grúas comandada por
varias decenas de estibadores permitió
descargar y volver a cargar sus 23.000
contenedores ya no está operación
implica movilizar personal para la carga
y descarga de los contenedores al
personal portuario del gran puerto de
dunkerque también activa a los
importadores exportadores agentes de
tránsito funcionarios aduaneros hay
mucho valor agregado y empleos asociados
a escalas como estas pero la llegada del
consell y se despertó expectativas
también pues el barco realizó sus tres
semanas de navegación propulsado por gas
licuado natural la más limpia de las
energías fósiles que permite reducir en
un 20% las emisiones de co2
responsable de un 3 por ciento de las
emanaciones globales de gases de efecto
invernadero imposibles que usamos aunque
eso todavía una parte del gas que
cargamos será bio y hay otras soluciones
como el etanol el amoniaco o el
hidrógeno pero y producir hidrógeno
limpio es muy difícil extremo difícil
para el capital y los 25 miembros de la
tripulación viajar desde asia con estas
fugas llenas de gas un verdadero desafío
efe porque todo está hecho para que en
la pasarela tenga total seguridad cuando
doy una orden el sistema responde
mecánicamente la instalación de gas es
muy compleja el peor escenario sería una
colisión con otro barco que podría
figurar la cuba o un choque en el muelle
ya que sólo dos buques de la naviera
funcionan hoy a gas pero a fines del
2000 vendidos un 7 por ciento de su
flota lo hará y es que por ahora sólo es
posible cargar gas en rotterdam y en la
costa este de eeuu